Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. So, football is coming home. Or is it? Might it be going to Rome? Dominic Sambret with me. A night of titanic passion and drama last night as the England football team, following in the footsteps of their Anglo-Saxon forebears,
感谢收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。想要获取每周的加更剧集、无广告收听体验、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。那么，足球要回家了。真的是这样吗？还是说它会去罗马？多米尼克·桑布雷特和我在一起。昨晚，英格兰足球队追随他们盎格鲁-撒克逊祖先的脚步，经历了一个充满激情与戏剧性的泰坦之夜，
who won at the battles of Eddington, of Teton Hall, of Brunanbur, smashed the Danish shield wall. Yes, it wasn't quite the smashing of the shield wall that you might have hoped for. No, I'm grotesquely exaggerating. It was tense. And the Danes were, I mean, they could claim they were a little bit unlucky. But it was, apart from the shining of laser pens and so on, which was probably... The laser pen of God. Yeah, which I think the Anglo-Saxons might have frowned upon. I thought, you know, the Danes bowed out very gallantly, as I hoped they would. We love the Danes.
那些曾在埃丁顿、泰顿霍尔、布鲁南堡战役中获胜的祖先们，击碎了丹麦人的盾墙。是的，这并不完全是你所希望的那种击碎盾墙。不，我夸张得太离谱了。比赛很紧张。丹麦人，我的意思是，他们可以说自己有点运气不佳。但除了激光笔的闪烁等等，这可能……上帝的激光笔。是的，我想盎格鲁-撒克逊人可能对此会皱眉头。我想，你知道，丹麦人非常大度地退出了比赛，正如我所希望的那样。我们爱丹麦人。
So the Danes are kind of our kin, aren't they? They're our northern brethren. So this time, the final is going to be very different because the Italians are people against whom we've defined ourselves, but in completely different ways. There are cultural opposites in various ways. I mean, we do have a really fascinating intertwined history, but they are the kind of stereotype, aren't they? They're the Mediterranean non-Britons, if you like. But looking at it in the broadest possible span,
所以丹麦人算是我们的亲戚，不是吗？他们是我们的北方兄弟。所以这一次，决赛将会非常不同，因为意大利人是我们用来定义自己的对象，但方式完全不同。他们在各个方面都是文化上的对立面。我的意思是，我们确实有着非常迷人且交织在一起的历史，但他们就是那种刻板印象，不是吗？如果你愿意的话，他们是地中海的非英国人。但从最广阔的角度来看，
I mean, I think you can make the case for saying that of all Europe's countries, perhaps none of them has had a profounder influence on our history than Italy. I think we've said that about every country, with the possible exception of Ukraine. No, I think we said that the rivalry between England and Denmark was the oldest, which I think is true. But I think that the influence that Italy has had in various manifestations and in various ways, I mean, it's kind of beyond profound. And the idea that we can sum it all up in 40, 50 minutes is ludicrous. But we should probably crack on, shouldn't we?
我的意思是，我认为你可以说，在欧洲所有国家中，也许没有哪个国家对我们的历史产生过比意大利更深远的影响。我想我们对每个国家都这么说过，除了乌克兰。不，我想我们说过英格兰和丹麦之间的竞争是最古老的，我认为这是事实。但我认为意大利在各种表现形式和各个方面产生的影响，我的意思是，这简直是深不可测。而且认为我们能在40、50分钟内总结这一切是荒谬的。但我们大概应该开始了，不是吗？
Yeah. If you're going to go back beyond the creation of Italy as a country, then of course that's true. Especially if you go back to one of your specialisms, which is where I imagine you're going to kick off. Well, it is because I thought we really need to define Italy in England. So Italy actually is much older than the founding of the Italian kingdom in the 19th century, because absolutely the Romans had a sense of Italy as a coherent identity, certainly by the early second century BC, possibly before that. And actually the beginning of the first century BC, when the various Italian peoples and cities rebel against Rome, they mint coins with the name Italia on it.
是的。如果你要追溯到意大利作为一个国家建立之前，那当然是真的。特别是如果你追溯到你的专业领域之一，我想你打算从那里开始。嗯，确实如此，因为我觉得我们真的需要在英格兰定义意大利。所以意大利实际上比19世纪意大利王国的建立要古老得多，因为罗马人肯定在公元前二世纪初，甚至可能更早之前，就有一种将意大利视为统一身份的意识。实际上，在公元前一世纪初，当各个意大利民族和城市反抗罗马时，他们铸造了刻有“Italia”字样的硬币。
And they proclaim a kind of a unitary Italy in opposition to Roman rule. So, you know, that's the kind of precursor for what happens in the 19th century that I think makes it legitimate to talk about Italy. Even though Italy then kind of went underground for so many centuries between those two points. is from italian it's from julius caesar who leads expeditions against britain in 55 bc 54 bc writes it up in massive self-promoting commentaries um self-aggrandizing the kind of thing that you would never do dominic and thank you tom and obviously the romans then invade permanently in 43 ad and um britain becomes part of the roman the Roman Empire for kind of four centuries. The Romans then withdraw and the Angles, the Saxons, the Jutes, according to later tradition, then invade and seize what had been the Roman province of Britannia. And this in due course becomes
他们宣布了一种与罗马统治相对立的统一的意大利。所以，你知道，这就是19世纪所发生之事的先驱，我认为这使得谈论意大利变得合法。尽管在那两个时间点之间的许多世纪里，意大利似乎“潜入地下”了。这是来自意大利，来自朱利叶斯·凯撒，他在公元前55年和54年领导了对英国的远征，并在大规模的自我宣传评论中写下了这些，嗯，自我吹嘘，这种事你永远不会做，多米尼克。谢谢你，汤姆。显然，罗马人在公元43年永久入侵，嗯，英国成为了罗马帝国的一部分，持续了大约四个世纪。随后罗马人撤离，根据后来的传统，盎格鲁人、撒克逊人、朱特人入侵并占领了曾经的罗马行省不列颠尼亚。这在适当的时候成为了
England. So when we're talking about England against Italy, really, I think we need to start looking at the Anglo-Saxons rather than say with Caraticus or Boudicca or you're not including if this was Wales v Italy which did happen earlier in the tournament you would have gone in with Boudicca and Caraticus and so on but you're disbarring them for the purposes of this podcast I think so there are arguments there are scholars who argue that um a form of proto-english was spoken in the eastern half of britain and there's an argument that buddhica is actually a pun so in celtic languages it it's it means victory victoria so that's why you get the statue of buddhica outside houses of parliament um suppose there was a kind of proto-English, a kind of Germanic language.
英格兰。所以当我们谈论英格兰对阵意大利时，真的，我认为我们需要开始关注盎格鲁-撒克逊人，而不是从卡拉塔库斯或布狄卡开始。如果你不包括——如果这是威尔士对阵意大利，这在锦标赛早些时候确实发生过——你可能会提到布狄卡和卡拉塔库斯等等，但我想你为了这期播客把他们排除在外了。所以，有学者认为，嗯，一种原始英语形式在英国东半部被使用，而且有一种观点认为布狄卡实际上是一个双关语，在凯尔特语中，它意味着胜利（Victoria），这就是为什么你在议会大厦外能看到布狄卡的雕像。假设有一种原始英语，一种日耳曼语言。
It's possible that, say, Wicca, as in Wicca now, the religion, means a woman. And it's possible that there's an illusion there that it means a woman who's been attacked or a woman who's been raped, which, of course, Boudicca was and precipitates the rebellion. So perhaps there are kind of pockets of proto-english being spoken but it's a highly controversial opinion not widely accepted and not one that i think we should be going into this is way too complicated i can see the rabbit hole beckoning but what i would say is that for the anglo-saxons rome is kind of central to their imagination it It's almost the capital of their imaginings. And they have a very, very profound emotional, spiritual relationship to the idea of Rome that I think basically provides
有可能，比如现在的“Wicca”（巫术），意思是女人。有可能这里有一个暗示，指代一个被攻击或被强奸的女人，当然，布狄卡就是这样，并引发了叛乱。所以也许有一些原始英语的碎片被使用，但这是一种极具争议的观点，并不被广泛接受，我认为我们不应该深入探讨。这太复杂了，我能看到兔子洞在招手。但我会说，对于盎格鲁-撒克逊人来说，罗马在某种程度上是他们想象力的核心。它几乎是他们想象的首都。他们对罗马的概念有着非常、非常深厚的情感和精神联系，我认为这基本上提供了
the seedbed from which English attitudes to Italy generally come from. So English kings, the very first English kings or the kings of the people we recognise as the English, did they see themselves, do you think, as the heirs to the Roman emperors? Minting coins and living maybe in the last kingdom of Bernard Cornwell series, their palaces are kind of in the ruins of Roman villas and things. Is that, do you think, how they saw themselves? I think they have a sense of themselves as peripheral to Rome. So in that sense, they still see themselves as kind of a colonial relationship to the metropolis. Because if you look at the Anglo-Saxon Chronicle, which is this kind of year by year account of history, it begins with Julius Caesar coming to Britain. And so in a sense, the Anglo-Saxons are
种子床，英国人对意大利的态度通常就源于此。那么，英国国王，最早的英国国王或我们认为是英国人的国王，你认为他们是否将自己视为罗马皇帝的继承人？铸造硬币，也许生活在伯纳德·康威尔系列小说中的最后一个王国里，他们的宫殿就在罗马别墅的废墟中等等。你认为他们是这样看待自己的吗？我认为他们有一种自己处于罗马边缘的感觉。所以从这个意义上说，他们仍然认为自己与大都市之间存在某种殖民关系。因为如果你看《盎格鲁-撒克逊编年史》，这种逐年的历史记录，它始于朱利叶斯·凯撒来到英国。所以从某种意义上说，盎格鲁-撒克逊人是
identifying the beginnings of their history with Rome's first contact with the island in which they will come to live. So that's kind of defining themselves through Rome. And again, if you look at Bede, who is the first great historian of England, so much of our information about Anglo-Saxon England in its beginnings comes from Bede. And his kind of opening, he describes Britain, which was once called Albion, he says, is an island in the ocean and it lies to the northwest. And what's fascinating about that is that Bede is situating Britain relative to Rome. So he's taking on a Roman perspective. So in that sense, there's still a kind of a hint of the
将他们历史的开端与罗马首次接触他们未来居住的岛屿联系起来。所以这是一种通过罗马来定义自己的方式。同样，如果你看比德，他是英国第一位伟大的历史学家，我们关于盎格鲁-撒克逊英格兰起源的很多信息都来自比德。他的开篇描述了英国，他说它曾经被称为阿尔比恩，是一个位于海洋中的岛屿，位于西北部。令人着迷的是，比德是相对于罗马来定位英国的。所以他采用了罗马的视角。所以从这个意义上说，仍然有一种
colonized to it. Yeah, Rome of the hint of the the colonized to it yeah rome is the center of the world rome and britain is on the at the edge okay i buy that i completely buy that i mean presumably all european peoples except the sort of scandinavians certainly all western european peoples but in their what people used to call the dark ages define themselves that way right rome used to be the center and it still is but there's there's a sense also i think i mean you asked about kings so even before england gets converted to the roman form of christianity um there's a group of of kings in um in east anglia probably the guys who who um who bury the um the ship at sutton who called the wolfingas. And scholars have argued that the name wolf that's embedded in that may well put it on their coins that make great riffs about the wolf. Of course,
被殖民者的暗示。是的，罗马是世界的中心，而英国处于边缘。好吧，我接受这一点，我完全接受。我的意思是，大概除了斯堪的纳维亚人之外的所有欧洲民族，当然所有西欧民族，在人们过去所说的“黑暗时代”都是这样定义自己的，对吧？罗马曾经是中心，现在依然是。但我认为也有一种感觉，我的意思是，你问到了国王，所以即使在英格兰皈依罗马形式的基督教之前，嗯，在东盎格利亚有一群国王，可能是那些埋葬萨顿胡船的人，他们被称为“Wolfingas”。学者们认为，嵌入其中的“狼”这个名字可能与此有关，他们把狼放在硬币上，大肆渲染狼。当然，
the wolf suckles Romulus and Remus. So perhaps that's a part of it. Certainly in their genealogy, like all the Anglo-Saxon kings, they trace it back to Woden, the king of the gods. But they distinctively say that the son of Woden was Caesar, and therefore they are descended from Caesar. And this is a tradition, you know, you ask, do the Anglo-Saxon kings kind of ape the model of imperial rule? They absolutely do. So the story is told of Alfred, he definitely goes to Rome on pilgrimage once, but he's supposed also to have gone um as a boy and to have been um blessed by the Pope and to have been anointed by him rather as Charlemagne did I mean this is most unlikely to have happened because there was no prospect at that point that Alfred was going to become king but it's a story that matters and it
狼哺育了罗穆卢斯和雷穆斯。所以也许这是其中的一部分。当然，在他们的家谱中，像所有的盎格鲁-撒克逊国王一样，他们追溯到众神之王沃登。但他们明确表示沃登的儿子是凯撒，因此他们是凯撒的后裔。这是一个传统，你知道，你问，盎格鲁-撒克逊国王是否模仿帝国统治的模式？他们绝对模仿了。所以关于阿尔弗雷德的故事是，他确实去过罗马朝圣一次，但据说他小时候也去过，并受到教皇的祝福和涂油，就像查理曼大帝那样。我的意思是，这不太可能发生，因为当时阿尔弗雷德没有成为国王的前景，但这是一个重要的故事，它
gets told in due course um Athelstan um Alfred's grandson he is the first king of the whole of England and he summons kings from across the north of Britain so those stretches of Britain that the Romans had never conquered kings of Scots kings from the Strathclyde and he summons them to a place called Amont in in Cumbria and what's significant about that place is that there's a Roman fortress there there There's a symbol of Roman power. And Athelstan then, he holds these kind of great derbars in Roman cities, presumably in the kind of amphitheaters that are still functional and which established the prototype for Wembley. Very good. That's where it all begins. who we mentioned in the podcast against Denmark, he has this very imperial coronation.
在适当的时候被讲述。嗯，埃塞尔斯坦，阿尔弗雷德的孙子，他是整个英格兰的第一位国王，他召集了来自英国北部各地的国王——那些罗马人从未征服过的英国地带——苏格兰国王、斯特拉斯克莱德的国王，他把他们召集到坎布里亚一个叫阿蒙特的地方。那个地方的意义在于那里有一座罗马堡垒，那里有罗马权力的象征。然后埃塞尔斯坦在罗马城市举行了这些盛大的朝觐，大概是在仍然可以使用的圆形剧场里，这确立了温布利的雏形。非常好。这就是一切开始的地方。我们在播客中提到的对抗丹麦的人，他有这种非常帝国的加冕礼。
And where does he choose to have it? In Bath, which is full of Roman buildings. The most extravagantly imperial city in Britain. So I think that that is absolutely a part of it, that there's a kind of a cultural cringe before the idea of the roman empire and a desire to emulate it so this is a very good start for italy in this podcast it's looking good so that's good so so we're yes so the kind of intimidating presence of the italian team we're flinching before it but yeah there's also stuff that we can learn because of course
他选择在哪里举行？在巴斯，那里到处都是罗马建筑。英国最奢华的帝国城市。所以我认为这绝对是其中的一部分，对罗马帝国的概念有一种文化上的自卑感，并有一种效仿它的渴望。所以这对这期播客中的意大利来说是一个很好的开始，看起来不错。所以很好，所以是的，意大利队那种令人生畏的存在，我们在它面前退缩了，但是的，也有我们可以学习的东西，因为当然
rome is not significant only as an imperial capital, as was, but as the city of the popes. Yes. I thought we'd get to the popes. The place where Peter and Paul are martyred, where the Bishop of Rome has his bishopric. And it's the Bishop of Rome who sends missionaries to convert the pagan Anglo-Saxons. and the guy who does that is gregory the great who is a massive punster a punster he's a punster he loves his puns right so he's a famous story that he goes out into the slave market in rome and he sees these blonde boys blonde children who've come from a kingdom called deira part of Northumbria in northern England. And he asks who they are, and he's told that they are Angles, Angli.
罗马不仅作为帝国首都具有重要意义，而且作为教皇之城。是的。我想我们会谈到教皇。彼得和保罗殉道的地方，罗马主教拥有主教辖区的地方。正是罗马主教派遣传教士去感化异教徒盎格鲁-撒克逊人。做这件事的人是格列高利大帝，他是一个超级双关语爱好者。双关语爱好者，他是个双关语爱好者，他喜欢双关语，对吧？所以有一个著名的故事，他走进罗马的奴隶市场，看到这些来自英格兰北部诺森布里亚一个叫德拉的王国的金发男孩、金发儿童。他问他们是谁，被告知他们是盎格鲁人（Angli）。
And he says, non-Angli, said Angeli, not Angles, but angels. And everyone collapses into laughter. And when he asks where they come from, he's told Daera. He says, ah, Daera, which means from anger. I have been called to rescue them from the anger of Satan. Oh, my word. I mean, a stream of terrible jokes. Yes.
他说：“Non Angli, sed Angeli”，不是盎格鲁人，而是天使。每个人都笑得前仰后合。当他问他们来自哪里时，被告知是“Daera”。他说：“啊，Daera，意思是来自愤怒（de ira）。我被召唤去拯救他们脱离撒旦的愤怒。”天哪。我的意思是，一连串糟糕的笑话。是的。
So this is like some sort of foreign football association in the 1990s saying we'll send you some coaches to break your long ball game and teach you how to play proper football. Exactly. We'll send you Claudio Ranieri and Gianluca Vialli and so on. Exactly. Well, actually, and the English end up, they take Gregory as their celestial patron. So they imagine that at the end of days, Gregory will plead their case before the throne of God. But they also, they set up a kind of training school in Rome.
所以这就像20世纪90年代的某个外国足球协会说，我们会派一些教练来打破你们的长传冲吊打法，教你们如何踢真正的足球。正是如此。我们会派克劳迪奥·拉涅利和詹卢卡·维亚利等等。正是如此。嗯，实际上，英格兰人最终接受格列高利作为他们的天国守护神。所以他们想象在世界末日，格列高利会在上帝的宝座前为他们辩护。但他们也建立了一个罗马培训学校。
So they set up a hostel where pilgrims can stay. It actually preserves a trace in the street plan of Rome to this day because they call it a burr. Oh, right, after Alfred's Burrs. After Alfred's Burrs. And so the Burgo Santo Spirito, which is the kind of the road that leads from the Tiber up to the piazza in front of St. Peter's,
所以他们建立了一个供朝圣者居住的旅馆。它实际上在罗马的街道规划中保留了痕迹，直到今天，因为他们称之为“Burgo”。哦，对了，以阿尔弗雷德的“Burhs”（堡垒）命名。以阿尔弗雷德的“Burhs”命名。所以“Burgo Santo Spirito”，就是从台伯河通往圣彼得大教堂前广场的那条路，
that preserves, you know, that derives from the Burg, which was there because that's where it stood. Very nice. But obviously the Pope, he goes on to be, you know, public enemy number one for generations of English men and women, doesn't he? I mean, even preceding the Reformation, there was a bad blood between the papacy and the English crown, right? Well, in the Anglo-Saxon period,
它保留了，你知道，它源于“Burg”，它之所以在那里是因为那就是它所在的地方。非常好。但显然教皇后来成为了几代英国男女的头号公敌，不是吗？我的意思是，即使在宗教改革之前，教皇和英国王室之间也存在积怨，对吧？嗯，在盎格鲁-撒克逊时期，
the sense that the Pope is their kind of godfather, I think is... The godfather, very nice. No one has an issue, you know, in every sense of the word. No one has an issue with that. Gregory VII, the kind of great reforming Pope of the 11th century, he sends, as we mentioned in our episode on 1066, he sends a banner to william the conqueror yes kind of wishing him good luck yeah and the reason that gregory the
教皇是他们的教父，这种感觉我认为是……教父，非常好。没有人有异议，你知道，在任何意义上。没有人有异议。格列高利七世，11世纪伟大的改革派教皇，正如我们在1066年的那一集中提到的，他送了一面旗帜给威廉征服者，是的，算是祝他好运。是的，而格列高利
seventh is so revolutionary a pope is that essentially he is the guy who pushes the idea that the pope should be superior to all earthly kings in a way that he hadn't been before yeah and that of course is what then generates the sense of tension. So you get it with Henry II after he's held responsible for the murder of Thomas Becket, that essentially he has to be kind of whipped through the streets of Canterbury to pay penance. And then, of course, in the reign of John,
七世之所以是一位如此革命性的教皇，是因为他本质上是推动教皇应该高于所有世俗国王这一理念的人，这在以前是没有的。是的，而这当然就是产生紧张感的原因。所以你在亨利二世被认为对托马斯·贝克特的谋杀负责后看到了这一点，他基本上必须在坎特伯雷的街道上被鞭打以赎罪。然后，当然，在约翰统治时期，
which we talked about in our episode of Magna Carta, John basically kind of has a massive bust up with Innocent III, who is a ferociously powerful and authoritarian Pope. And John is broken by it and ends up offering England as a papal fiefdom. He holds it in trust from the Pope. And I think that probably does kind of establish a slight legacy of tension. So during all that period, I mean, the italian the the english as it were the other the whipping boys is too strong but we're definitely in a sort of to borrow your phrase from the beginning there's an element of cultural cringe right i think so that the the rome is where it is the papacy is the sort of you know gods the pope is god's vicar on earth and english kings
我们在大宪章那一集中谈到过，约翰基本上与英诺森三世发生了巨大的冲突，他是一位极其强大和专制的教皇。约翰被击垮了，最终提出将英格兰作为教皇的封地。他代教皇托管它。我认为这可能确实建立了一种轻微的紧张遗产。所以在那整个时期，我的意思是，意大利人，英国人，正如他们所说，其他人，替罪羊这个词太强了，但我们绝对处于一种——借用你开头的话——有一种文化自卑感，对吧？我认为是这样，罗马就是它所在的地方，教皇是上帝在人间的代理人，而英国国王
sort of basically, you know, they can try to weasel their way out as John did or as Henry II, you know, by killing the Archbishop of Canterbury. But basically the Pope is the power broker. He's the dominant figure in that relationship. Yeah, it's the centre. I mean, it's the great place of pilgrimage. Jerusalem is under Muslim rule. Yeah.
基本上，你知道，他们可以像约翰那样试图溜之大吉，或者像亨利二世那样，你知道，通过杀死坎特伯雷大主教。但基本上教皇是权力掮客。他是那种关系中的主导人物。是的，它是中心。我的意思是，它是伟大的朝圣之地。耶路撒冷处于穆斯林统治之下。是的。
So it's too far. But Rome is, you know, for most of the middle ages apart from when the popes go to avignon is the that's the that's the kind of the great court and it's an earthly as well as a spiritual power so um absolutely um england has a kind of peripheral relationship to it and on top of that of course and italy is also a cultural and an economic powerhouse increasingly. Yeah, I was going to ask about this. As the Middle Ages progress. The cultural relationship.
所以太远了。但罗马是，你知道，对于中世纪的大部分时间来说，除了教皇去阿维尼翁的时候，那是伟大的宫廷，它既是世俗权力也是精神权力。所以，嗯，绝对的，嗯，英格兰与它有一种边缘关系，最重要的是，当然，意大利也是一个文化和经济强国，而且日益增强。是的，我正要问这个问题。随着中世纪的推进。文化关系。
So people like, let's say, Chaucer. I mean, Chaucer must have a sense of Italian culture and all that stuff, does he? Absolutely. And it's kind of interwoven with the economic power, because the reason that Chaucer goes to Italy is to negotiate trade deals over wool. He wants to improve trade deals cutting out middlemen, so that this boosts trade and boosts the amount of money that goes directly into English coffers, rather than to middlemen in the lowlandslands so chaucer goes to genoa he then goes on to
所以像乔叟这样的人。我的意思是，乔叟一定对意大利文化和所有这些东西有某种感觉，对吧？绝对的。而且它与经济力量交织在一起，因为乔叟去意大利的原因是为了谈判羊毛贸易协议。他想改善贸易协议，剔除中间商，这样可以促进贸易，增加直接进入英国国库的资金，而不是流向低地国家的中间商。所以乔叟去了热那亚，然后去了
florence um and of course in florence he may well have met bacaccio who is the um author of the camera yes so this kind of great series of interlinked tales which almost you know provides a model for the canterbury tales and he may have seen giottoto, Giotto's paintings. So he's, Chaucer is a very European figure and hugely influenced by kind of, you know, Italian culture is massively significant for him. As it is basically for every cutting edge English writer, artist. Italy is the cultural centre. But there's also that sense, you know know he's going there because italy is incredibly rich and again england is kind of economically supported i mean not entirely so edward so you start to get banks in italy these banking families yeah so edward i borrows obscene
佛罗伦萨，当然，在佛罗伦萨，他很可能见过《十日谈》的作者薄伽丘。是的，所以这一系列伟大的互相关联的故事，几乎（你知道）为《坎特伯雷故事集》提供了模型，他可能见过乔托，乔托的画作。所以他是，乔叟是一个非常欧洲化的人物，深受意大利文化的影响，这对他是极其重要的。正如它基本上对每一个尖端的英国作家、艺术家一样。意大利是文化中心。但也有那种感觉，你知道，他去那里是因为意大利极其富有，而英格兰在经济上是某种被支持的，我的意思是，不完全是。所以爱德华，你开始在意大利看到银行，这些银行家族。是的，所以爱德华一世从卢卡的一个银行家族借了巨额
amounts from a banking family in Lucca. And then there's a war between England and France. There's a kind of snarl up. There's a credit crunch. Edward needs money from this banking family. He demands it. They can't pay it because they don't have access to ready cash. So Edward then appropriates all their belongings in England.
资金。然后英格兰和法国之间发生了战争。出现了一种僵局。出现了信贷紧缩。爱德华需要这笔钱，他要求归还。他们无法支付，因为他们没有现钱。所以爱德华随后没收了他们在英格兰的所有财产。
It's poor form, isn't it? It's a very poor form. It kind of destroys this bank. But it also cripples England's economy because from that point on it was self-destructive, completely self-destructive behaviour. Yes. And over the course of the 14th century, English kings keep kind of having to agree
这很不体面，不是吗？这非常不体面。它在某种程度上摧毁了这家银行。但也削弱了英格兰的经济，因为从那时起，这是一种自我毁灭的、完全自我毁灭的行为。是的。在14世纪的过程中，英国国王不断地不得不同意
ever more humiliating terms and then get driven to default. And basically England in the 14th century, I mean, it's the Argentina of the European economy. Apologies to our Argentine listeners there. But it has a third world relationship to the IMF. Yeah. It's that kind of thing.
越来越屈辱的条款，然后被迫违约。基本上14世纪的英格兰，我的意思是，它是欧洲经济的阿根廷。向我们的阿根廷听众道歉。但它与国际货币基金组织（IMF）有着第三世界式的关系。是的。就是那种感觉。
So I think, you know, England is, in this episode, it's very much a game of two halves. And the first half, England is kind of losing 6-0. Right. That's very disappointing. What about the Lombard? Where do the Lombards come in, Tom? Are we at Lombard Street and Lombard Bankers?
所以我认为，你知道，英格兰，在这一集中，这非常像一场两半的比赛。上半场，英格兰输了6-0。对。这非常令人失望。伦巴第人怎么样？伦巴第人在哪里出现，汤姆？我们是在伦巴第街和伦巴第银行家那里吗？
Is that this stage or is that later? Yeah, so Lombard Street is the main, I mean, it's called the Wall Street of London, isn't it? It's kind of the great concentration of banks now running from Bank Tube Station. And it's named after goldsmiths from Lombardy. And again, it's Edward I. He gives these goldsmiths from Lombardy a plot of land. And that's what they then give their name to what becomes Lombard Street. So again, you see that, again, a bit like a kind of a third world economy wanting to attract inward investment, or indeed Britain now actually,
这是这个阶段还是后来？是的，所以伦巴第街是主要的，我的意思是，它被称为伦敦的华尔街，不是吗？它现在是银行的巨大集中地，从银行地铁站延伸出来。它以来自伦巴第的金匠命名。同样，是爱德华一世。他给了这些来自伦巴第的金匠一块土地。这就是他们后来给后来成为伦巴第街的地方命名的方式。所以同样，你看到了，这有点像一个第三世界经济体想要吸引外资，或者实际上现在的英国，
wanting to attract inward investment. You're in an inferior position to those who are able to hand out the economic patronage um so again that's a kind of another index you're not getting um italian cities kind of giving plots of land to english merchants because they don't need it if you're a sort of very bright successful italian i mean england is not really the place you'd move to right i mean i know italians do so john cabot the explorer was originally I don't know, what was he, Giovanni Cabot or something like that, wasn't he? I've probably got that completely wrong,
想要吸引外资。你处于比那些能够发放经济赞助的人更低的位置。所以同样，这是另一个指标，你不会看到意大利城市给英国商人土地，因为他们不需要。如果你是一个非常聪明、成功的意大利人，我的意思是，英格兰并不是你搬去的地方，对吧？我的意思是，我知道意大利人会去，所以探险家约翰·卡博特最初是——我不知道，他是什么，乔瓦尼·卡博特之类的，不是吗？我可能完全搞错了，
but I think it's something along those lines. But by and large, an ambitious young Italian, if you're from a banking family or you want to go out and seek your fortune in the world, England is not the obvious destination because it's a bit of a backwater. I mean, your obvious destination is presumably France or or or yeah you know castile or somewhere i think that's true i mean you know obviously that you do famously you get the venetian ambassadors whose um accounts of yeah they're always writing the murderous doings in in england is yeah incredibly
但我认为大概是这样。但总的来说，一个雄心勃勃的年轻意大利人，如果你来自银行家族，或者你想出去在世界上寻求财富，英格兰不是显而易见的目的地，因为它有点像个死水。我的意思是，你显而易见的目的地大概是法国，或者卡斯蒂利亚，或者其他地方。我认为这是真的，我的意思是，你知道，显然你确实有名地得到了威尼斯大使，他们的记录，是的，他们总是写下英格兰的谋杀行为，这是，是的，极其
useful source um but it is a bit like you again, a kind of IMF official writing reports from a war-torn dictatorship. From La Paz or something. Yes, a bit like that, I think. And then, of course, the relationship becomes massively complicated in the 16th century with the Reformation. Yes, because obviously the popes are all Italian at this stage, right? That's right, isn't it? So all the popes that Henry VIII falls out with, they are Italians. And Rome itself, I've always wondered whether that point you made earlier about the map that people have, whether that plays a part
有用的来源。但这有点像你，再次，一个国际货币基金组织的官员在战乱的独裁国家写报告。从拉巴斯或其他地方。是的，有点像那样，我想。然后，当然，这种关系在16世纪随着宗教改革变得极其复杂。是的，因为显然教皇在这个阶段都是意大利人，对吧？那是对的，不是吗？所以亨利八世与之闹翻的所有教皇，他们都是意大利人。而罗马本身，我一直想知道你之前提到的关于人们地图的那一点，是否在
in the Reformation imagination. So Rome has always been the centre of the world. And when Henry says, you know, this realm of ours is an empire and, you know, basically sod the Pope and all his cardinals and we don't care what they think, there's a sense of, you know, we're sick of being the puppet controlled by the puppet master. And there is almost the element of rebelling against the cringe in that. Yeah, well, I mean, the very fact that Henry is forced into, you know, kind of throwing the Pope out,
宗教改革的想象中发挥了作用。所以罗马一直是世界的中心。当亨利说，你知道，我们这个王国是一个帝国，而且，你知道，基本上管他妈的教皇和他的所有红衣主教，我们不在乎他们怎么想，有一种感觉，你知道，我们厌倦了成为被傀儡大师控制的傀儡。这几乎有一种反抗那种自卑感的成分。是的，嗯，我的意思是，亨利被迫，你知道，某种程度上把教皇赶走，
abandoning the English church's loyalty to the papacy is an index of England's marginal status. Because the reason that the Pope can't grant the divorce to Henry is because the Pope has been captured by Charles V, the Emperor. Yes. And Catherine of Aragon is his aunt. Yeah. So Henry doesn't register in the balance. Yeah, he's just not as important, is he? Just not as important.
放弃英国教会对教皇的忠诚，本身就是英格兰边缘地位的一个指标。因为教皇不能批准亨利离婚的原因是教皇被查理五世皇帝俘虏了。是的。而阿拉贡的凯瑟琳是他的姑姑。是的。所以亨利在平衡中没有被考虑。是的，他只是没那么重要，不是吗？只是没那么重要。
I mean, we've got henry the eighth podcast to come and henry's always he's always trying to be on at center stage with the king of france and the emperor but he's very much clearly the third man in that kind of relationship which clearly irritates him i always wonder whether that's why he became so fat because he's just desperate to kind of push them off stage and make himself look bigger. More important than he was. But I think, I mean, that does then recalibrate, obviously, England's relationship, not just with the Roman church,
我的意思是，我们还有关于亨利八世的播客要录，亨利总是，他总是试图和法国国王和皇帝一起站在舞台中央，但他显然是那种关系中的第三者，这显然让他很恼火。我一直想知道这就是他变得那么胖的原因，因为他只是绝望地想把他们推下舞台，让自己看起来更大。比他实际更重要。但我认为，我的意思是，这确实重新校准了，显然，英格兰的关系，不仅是与罗马教会，
but with Italian culture generally. Italy remains very much the kind of sun around which people of culture revolve. And I suppose the classic example of that would be Shakespeare. Loads of whose plays are set in Italy. Well, I really wanted to ask about Shakespeare, because there is a theory, isn't there, an outlandish theory, it seems to me, that Shakespeare,
而且与意大利文化的关系。意大利仍然非常像是文化人围绕旋转的太阳。我想经典的例子就是莎士比亚。他的很多剧作都以意大利为背景。嗯，我真的很想问关于莎士比亚的问题，因为有一个理论，不是吗，一个在我看来很离谱的理论，即莎士比亚，
well, it's one of these many conspiracy theories that the Shakespearean plays were not written by a man called William Shakespeare, but there's one theory that they were written by an Italian, or a man of Italian extraction called John Florio. Are you aware of this? I wasn't. Tell me more. Oh, I was hoping you were aware of it.
嗯，这是众多阴谋论之一，即莎士比亚的剧作不是由一个叫威廉·莎士比亚的人写的，但有一个理论说它们是由一个意大利人，或者一个叫约翰·弗洛里奥的意大利裔人写的。你知道这个吗？我不知道。告诉我更多。哦，我本来希望你知道的。
That's basically all I know. Well, I know that there's a quite widely held theory that Shakespeare has these missing years. Yes. And nobody quite knows where he went. And the familiarity that he shows with Italy. theory that Shakespeare has these missing years and nobody quite knows where he went and the familiarity that he shows with Italy Well exactly, this is the
我基本上只知道这些。嗯，我知道有一个相当普遍的理论，即莎士比亚有这些失踪的岁月。是的。没人确切知道他去了哪里。而他表现出的对意大利的熟悉程度……理论说莎士比亚有这些失踪的岁月，没人确切知道他去了哪里，而他表现出的对意大利的熟悉程度……嗯，完全正确，这就是
Florio thing, that Shakespeare knows too much about Italy Thomas Cromwell who launches the whole Reformation in England he had been in Italy so that's kind of quite a tried and tested path and the theory is that maybe Shakespeare went there as a mercenary or a teacher or whatever.
弗洛里奥的事情，莎士比亚对意大利了解得太多了。托马斯·克伦威尔，他在英格兰发起了整个宗教改革，他曾在意大利待过，所以这是一种相当久经考验的路径，理论是也许莎士比亚作为雇佣兵或老师或其他什么人去了那里。
But Shakespeare's geography is dodgy, isn't it? Because it's in The Winter's Tale where somebody gets a ship to Vienna or something like that. From Bohemia. From Bohemia. That's it, from Bohemia. But I don't think anyone's suggesting he went to Bohemia. But you think of all the plays that are set in Venice and Rome and, of course, Verona. Yeah, Romeo and Juliet.
但莎士比亚的地理知识很糟糕，不是吗？因为在《冬天的故事》里，有人坐船去了维也纳之类的。从波希米亚。从波希米亚。就是这样，从波希米亚。但我认为没人暗示他去了波希米亚。但你想到所有以威尼斯、罗马为背景的剧作，当然还有维罗纳。是的，《罗密欧与朱丽叶》。
I suppose now, so what does that mean to those people who are seeing it, do you think, at the sort of turn of the end of the 16th, beginning of the 17th century, when they're seeing this play set in Italy? Does that denote, I mean, that presumably doesn't denote, even though Italy is the home of the Pope and Rome is the sort of headquarters of the Antichrist in people's minds. Presumably, they have no problem with seeing plays set in Italy with a sympathetic Italian character.
我想现在，那么这对那些在16世纪末、17世纪初看到它的人意味着什么，你认为，当他们看到这部以意大利为背景的剧时？这是否意味着，我的意思是，这大概并不意味着，尽管意大利是教皇的家园，而罗马在人们心目中是反基督者的总部。大概，他们对看到以意大利为背景、有同情的意大利角色的剧作没有问题。
And that must still denote to them high culture, sophistication, lovely weather, citrus fruits. Yes, and even if you think about it, there's a very sympathetic portrait of the friar who weds Romeo and Juliet. Yes. He's not a kind of particular object of abuse in the play.
而且那一定仍然向他们传达了高雅文化、精致、宜人的天气、柑橘类水果。是的，即使你仔细想想，剧中对为罗密欧与朱丽叶证婚的修士的刻画也非常同情。是的。他在剧中并不是一个特别的攻击对象。
Yeah, he's not a Jesuit sort of conspirator. So maybe that reflects sympathy for Catholicism in Shakespeare's part. Lots of people have argued that. It's so difficult to know because Shakespeare's character is so opaque. Yes. But if you compare that with other playwrights who are doing portrayals of Italy at the same time, they're much more propagandistic. So you have all these Jacobean tragedies where you only have to have a cardinal and he's, you know, fancying his sister and poisoning people and that kind of thing,
是的，他不是那种耶稣会式的阴谋家。所以也许这反映了莎士比亚对天主教的同情。很多人都这样争论过。这太难知道了，因为莎士比亚的性格太模糊了。是的。但如果你把它与其他同时期描绘意大利的剧作家相比，他们更具宣传性。所以你有所有这些詹姆斯一世时期的悲剧，你只需要有一个红衣主教，他就是，你知道，看上了他的妹妹，毒害人，诸如此类的事情，
poisoning Bibles and kissing skulls and things like that. And in those plays, Italy is portrayed as an absolute kind of sump of potpourri, depravity, murder, rape, incest, every sin possibly going is there, is taking part. And I think that that does kind of mark a sea change in England's relationship to Italy, which is perhaps summed up by Milton, kind of devout Protestant, Puritan, going to Italy. And Milton is hugely, profoundly influenced
毒害圣经，亲吻头骨之类的。在那些剧作中，意大利被描绘成一个绝对的腐败、堕落、谋杀、强奸、乱伦的污水坑，每一个可能的罪恶都在那里发生。我认为这确实标志着英格兰与意大利关系的巨大转变，这也许可以由弥尔顿来总结，虔诚的新教徒、清教徒，去意大利。而弥尔顿深受
by Italian culture. You know, he speaks Italian fluently. He's absolutely versed in the works of influenced by Italian culture. He speaks Italian fluently. He's absolutely versed in the works of the great Italian poets. Mr. Red Dante and all that stuff. Yes, absolutely. But he goes to Italy on a kind of cultural pilgrimage, obviously not a pilgrimage of the kind that his English forebears had because he's Puritan.
意大利文化的深刻影响。你知道，他能流利地说意大利语。他绝对精通伟大的意大利诗人的作品。读过但丁和所有那些东西。是的，绝对的。但他去意大利进行了一种文化朝圣，显然不是他英国祖先那种朝圣，因为他是清教徒。
But one person he does go to see supposedly is Galileo. And he references it in Paradise Lost, his great poem. And he says Galileo is a great man. He has opened up untold worlds, unglimpsed worlds. And it's Milton really who articulates what will become the great myth that Galileo has been silenced and tortured by the Inquisition, by all the evil apparatus of the Roman Church. Hold on, is that a myth? It's a myth to the degree that Galileo is not tortured. He's not imprisoned. Right. He was put under enormous pressure though, wasn't he?
但他确实去见的一个人据说是伽利略。他在他的伟大诗作《失乐园》中提到了这一点。他说伽利略是一个伟大的人。他开启了未知的世界，未曾一瞥的世界。而真正阐述了后来成为伟大神话的人是弥尔顿，即伽利略被宗教裁判所、被罗马教会所有邪恶的机构所压制和折磨。等等，那是一个神话吗？在伽利略没有受到折磨的程度上，这是一个神话。他没有被监禁。对。但他确实承受了巨大的压力，不是吗？
He's put under pressure. though wasn't he he's put under pressure um but i think we should do an episode on galilee because the whole story is so fascinating describing this pressure in a very blasé way i have to say what i would say is that that milton bigs up the repressive character of the roman church yeah in a way that will have an enduring influence on the way that protestants see the catholic church's relationship to astronomy to the sciences that's how i've been in the long and that then in the long run bleeds into the way that say atheists or secularists like to cast it yeah it's basically it's a protestant myth philip bullman is a great i mean so philip bullman is the heir of mil in this regard, isn't he? Well, obviously Paradise Lost plays an enormous part in Philip Pullman's.
他承受了压力，不是吗？他承受了压力。嗯，但我认为我们应该做一期关于伽利略的节目，因为整个故事太迷人了。以一种非常冷漠的方式描述这种压力，我不得不说。我会说的是，弥尔顿夸大了罗马教会的压制性特征，是的，以一种将对新教徒看待天主教会与科学的关系的方式产生持久影响的方式。这就是我长期以来的看法，而这最终会融入到，比如说，无神论者或世俗主义者喜欢将其描述的方式中。是的，基本上这是一个新教神话。菲利普·普尔曼是一个伟大的——我的意思是，菲利普·普尔曼在这方面是弥尔顿的继承人，不是吗？嗯，显然《失乐园》在菲利普·普尔曼的作品中扮演了巨大的角色。
And so Philip Pullman, I imagine, is not a, I mean, I don't know if he's a listener to this podcast. Let's assume not. He's not a great Italianophile in that sense. He would probably sign up to the sort of black legend. I mean, black legend is Spain, isn't it? But it's kind of equivalent. The black legend that cast the Roman church as a kind of sump of repressiveness and ignorance and bigotry and intolerance is, I mean, there are elements of truth in it, but it gets massively amplified by English Protestants. And it has then, because England and America have culturally been Protestant, it's kind of bled into post-Christian attitudes,
所以菲利普·普尔曼，我想，不是一个——我的意思是，我不知道他是否是这个播客的听众。我们假设不是。他不是那种意义上的意大利爱好者。他可能会认同那种“黑色传说”。我的意思是，黑色传说是西班牙，不是吗？但它是一种等价物。将罗马教会描绘成一种压制、无知、偏执和不宽容的污水坑的黑色传说，我的意思是，其中有真实的成分，但它被英国新教徒极大地放大了。而且它，因为英格兰和美国在文化上一直是新教国家，它已经融入了后基督教的态度，
you know, hostility towards Christianity, which is often a kind of anti-Catholicism, really. Now the producer is telling us we have to go for a break. But I think that's the perfect moment, Dominic, because I think this has been very much a game of two halves. And the first half, Italy's dominated, but I think there's hope for England to come back in the second half okay jolly good I was just about to say and I'll just put it in um because it fits here just before we go for the break so Italy are winning but um this is just a sort of footnote to that we had a
你知道，对基督教的敌意，这通常实际上是一种反天主教情绪。现在制作人告诉我们必须去休息一下。但我认为这是完美的时刻，多米尼克，因为我认为这确实是一场两半的比赛。上半场，意大利占据了优势，但我认为英格兰在下半场有反击的希望。好的，太好了。我正要说，我会把它放进去，嗯，因为它在这里很合适，就在我们去休息之前。所以意大利赢了，但嗯，这只是一个脚注，我们有一个
listener called Mikey who said if you don't are you going to mention Mary of Modena in your podcast if you don't I won't tell you exactly what he said but he would say he would soil himself in a warming pan um so we have to mention her and i think this is the moment so mary modern was the wife of um james the second wasn't she and she gave birth unexpectedly to a healthy baby boy just before the door is revolution well this is the question or was a baby smuggled in a warming pan hence mikey's threat well when, when James II was kicked out, where did he go? Well, where did the Jacobites end up? I mean, the headquarters of Jacobitism was Rome, actually, and that sort of cemented, I think, Rome's reputation
叫迈基的听众说，如果你不——你会提到摩德纳的玛丽在你的播客里吗？如果你不提，我不会告诉你他确切说了什么，但他会说他会在暖床器里弄脏自己。所以我们必须提到她，我认为这就是时刻。所以摩德纳的玛丽是詹姆斯二世的妻子，不是吗？她在光荣革命前夕意外生下了一个健康的男婴。嗯，这就是问题所在，还是婴儿是用暖床器偷运进来的？因此迈基的威胁。嗯，当詹姆斯二世被赶走时，他去了哪里？嗯，詹姆斯党最终去了哪里？我的意思是，詹姆斯党的总部实际上是罗马，这在某种程度上巩固了，我认为，罗马的声誉
as the sort of anti-England par excellence, don't you think? So the old pretender, the young pretender, and then the last Jacobite, who I think was Henry the... Was he Henry the ninth as they called him he was cardinal and there's a monument to them still in Rome a monument that presumably all sort of Protestant Englishmen when they go on their trudging around St Peter's they regard with horror because I think it's somewhere in St Peter's so so that's just to me is the sort of tipping point because that's the point at which Rome is associated with losers, the Jacobites.
作为反英格兰的典范，你不觉得吗？所以老僭位者、小僭位者，然后是最后的詹姆斯党，我想是亨利……他是亨利九世，正如他们所称的那样，他是红衣主教，在罗马仍然有他们的纪念碑。一个纪念碑，大概所有那种新教英国人在他们蹒跚走过圣彼得大教堂时，都怀着恐惧看着它，因为我想它在圣彼得大教堂的某个地方。所以，对我来说，这就是转折点，因为那是罗马与失败者——詹姆斯党——联系在一起的点。
And obviously at that point the engines of kind of English and then British capitalism and there's a sense of Britain kind of overtaking Italy and hopefully we will make a second half comeback based on all that. So we'll see you after the break. episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com.
显然在那个时候，英国和后来的英国资本主义的引擎，有一种英国正在超越意大利的感觉，希望我们能基于所有这些在下半场卷土重来。所以我们休息后再见。剧集和抢先观看现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。
Hello, welcome back to the second half of England against Italy. As I said in the first half, I think this is going to be very much a game of two halves. First half, it was all Italy, all over the English. But I think now there's every chance that england can do a comeback um dominic i i'm afraid i completely i completely hogged that first time no no it's quite right i think everybody enjoyed it well i think anyway but the second half you've got lots of good stuff and it all seems to be food based well there's a lot about pasta and biscuits yeah i think that's what people have come to this podcast for, to be honest.
你好，欢迎回到英格兰对阵意大利比赛的下半场。正如我在上半场所说，我认为这绝对会是一场截然不同的半场比赛。上半场完全是意大利的天下，英格兰队被全面压制。但我认为现在英格兰完全有机会实现逆转。嗯，多米尼克，恐怕我刚才完全占用了上半场的时间。不，不，这很正常，我想大家都听得很开心，至少我是这么认为的。但下半场你准备了很多精彩内容，而且似乎都和食物有关。嗯，有很多关于意大利面和饼干的内容。说实话，我想这正是大家收听这个播客的原因。
I don't think they've come about that. They didn't go down by the Pope. They just want the bloody biscuits. Right. So let's start. I think we should start with the Grand Tour. Because the Grand Tour, as a lot of people know, is a sort of 18th century phenomenon,
我不认为他们是为了这个来的。他们不是为了教皇来的。他们只是想要那些该死的饼干。好吧。那我们开始吧。我认为我们应该从“壮游”（Grand Tour）开始。因为正如许多人所知，壮游是18世纪的一种现象，
late 17th, early 18th century phenomenon of people going rich, young aristocrats and whatnot would kind of go on this great expedition, almost like a colossal gap year um they'd go to france then they'd sometimes go to switzerland and they always end up in italy i mean italy was always the place and and i guess this really reinforces what you were saying in the first half about the importance of rome and the legacy of the roman empire because that's what they're going to see isn't it they're going to see roman ruins i mean gibbon edward gibbon Gibbon, who I worship as this sort of titanic historian. A wise, sceptical historian.
是17世纪末、18世纪初的一种现象，当时富有的年轻贵族之类的人会进行这种伟大的远征，几乎就像是一次巨大的间隔年。他们会去法国，有时会去瑞士，最后总是会到达意大利。我的意思是，意大利一直都是那个目的地。我想这确实加强了你上半场所说的关于罗马的重要性以及罗马帝国遗产的观点，因为他们去那里就是为了看这些，不是吗？他们去看罗马遗迹。我的意思是，吉本，爱德华·吉本，我崇拜的那位泰坦般的历史学家。一位睿智、怀疑论的历史学家。
Exactly. Like an owl. You couldn't have, no, I couldn't have put it better myself. So Gibbon goes in 1763 to four and there's this famous you know he has these famous lines um i shouldn't i can neither forget nor express the strong emotions which agitated my mind as i first approached and entered the eternal city and all this stuff and then he says you know to to be in the forum the place where romulus was where cicero spoke where caesar fell and he and he's he's almost drunk with excitement and it's then it was a little bit later that he's almost drunk with excitement. And it's then, or it's a little bit later,
没错。就像一只猫头鹰。你说的太对了，我无法表达得更好。所以吉本在1763年到1764年间去了那里，他有那些著名的台词。嗯，我不应该……我既无法忘记也无法表达当我第一次接近并进入这座永恒之城时，内心所激荡的强烈情感，诸如此类。然后他说，你知道，身处广场，那个罗慕路斯曾经所在的地方，西塞罗曾经演讲的地方，凯撒倒下的地方。他几乎因兴奋而醉了。那是后来发生的事，他几乎因兴奋而醉了。那是后来，或者说稍微晚一点的时候，
that he's famously sitting among the ruins of the Capitol while the friars are singing Vespers in the Temple of Jupiter. And he has the idea of writing his decline and fall of the Roman Empire. So you get this sort of sense of how in the 18th century, Rome still, some of the anti-Catholicism has faded, but you still have this sense of the sort of colossal sway. And that's kind of widespread, I think, across. So Dr. Johnson says a man who hasn't been to Italy is always conscious of an inferiority
他坐在卡比托利欧山的废墟中，当时修士们正在朱庇特神庙里唱晚祷。他产生了撰写《罗马帝国衰亡史》的想法。所以你可以感受到在18世纪，罗马依然……虽然一些反天主教的情绪已经消退，但你仍然能感受到那种巨大的影响力。我认为这在当时很普遍。所以约翰逊博士说，一个没去过意大利的人总是会感到自卑，
because he hasn't seen what a man ought to see. That's true. That's true. But it's also, it's ruins, isn't it? It is ruins. So the English lords and people like Gibbon and so on are going to see ruins. Yeah. And they're the ones with the cash.
因为他没有见过一个人应该见到的东西。那是真的。那是真的。但这也是废墟，不是吗？确实是废墟。所以英国的贵族们和像吉本这样的人去那里就是为了看废墟。是的。而且他们是那些有钱的人。
They're the ones with the big carriages. And basically they're there to gawp at, you know, the remnants of Italian greatness and to bring back loot. Well, they do, but they also go for, some of them go for more sordid reasons, more bodily reasons, Tom, because do you know what Boswell wrote? A typical line from Boswell's diaries of his time in Italy? I can imagine. Well, they do, but some of them go for more sordid reasons, more bodily reasons, Tom. Do you know what Boswell wrote, a typical line from Boswell's diaries of his time in Italy? I can imagine.
他们是那些坐着大马车的人。基本上他们去那里是为了盯着意大利伟大的遗迹看，并带回战利品。嗯，他们确实这么做了，但有些人去还有更卑劣的原因，更肉欲的原因，汤姆。因为你知道鲍斯威尔写了什么吗？鲍斯威尔在意大利期间的日记里有一句典型的话？我可以想象。嗯，他们确实这么做了，但有些人去还有更卑劣的原因，更肉欲的原因，汤姆。你知道鲍斯威尔写了什么吗？鲍斯威尔在意大利期间的日记里有一句典型的话？我可以想象。
Yesterday morning with her, pulled up petticoat and showed whole knees. I was touched with her goodness. All other liberties exquisite. That's exactly how I'd expect. He's Scottish, though, isn't he? So maybe that doesn't really count. Also, he was hardly remiss in undertaking similar research in London. So all these guys go for the grand tour, right?
昨天早上和她在一起，拉起衬裙，露出了整个膝盖。我被她的善良所触动。所有其他的自由都非常美妙。这正是我所预料的。不过他是苏格兰人，不是吗？所以也许那并不算数。而且，他在伦敦进行类似的研究时也一点都不懈怠。所以所有这些家伙都去参加壮游，对吧？
And this is going to bring me to what I really want to talk about, which is macaroni. So all these people go for the grand tour. Now, macaroni was known in England because the first recipe for macaroni cheese comes from, I think, the very beginning of the 14th century in a book about curry. That's confusing. That's a recipe for macaroni cheese.
这就要引出我真正想谈的话题了，那就是通心粉（macaroni）。所以所有这些人去参加壮游。现在，通心粉在英国是众所周知的，因为第一份通心粉奶酪的食谱来自14世纪初的一本关于咖喱的书。这很令人困惑。那是一份通心粉奶酪的食谱。
But clearly macaroni had been forgotten in the intervening period because all these people, they get a recipe for macaroni cheese. But clearly macaroni had been forgotten in the intervening period because all these people, they get a taste for macaroni when they're in Italy and then they come back and they bring back not just their enthusiasm for macaroni, but Italian-style dress. I mean, there were some absolutely hilarious quotations. So they say, I don't know whether it sort of starts as a saying among themselves, sort of these sort of trust affair and gap year veterans. They say, oh, you're looking very macaroni today, darling, or whatever. And then people start to mock them. So this is the
但显然，通心粉在随后的时期里被遗忘了，因为所有这些人，他们在意大利时尝到了通心粉的味道，然后他们回来时，不仅带回了对通心粉的热情，还带回了意大利风格的服装。我的意思是，有一些绝对令人捧腹的引语。所以他们说，我不知道这是否是在他们自己人之间开始的一种说法，那些壮游和间隔年的老手们。他们说，哦，亲爱的，你今天看起来很“通心粉”啊，或者诸如此类的。然后人们开始嘲笑他们。所以这是
Oxford Magazine in 1770. There's indeed a kind of animal, neither male nor female, a thing of the neuter gender, lately started up among us. It is called a macaroni. It talks without meaning. It smiles without pleasantry. It eats without appetite. It rides without exercise. It wenches without passion. So there's a sort of sense of effeminacy. And basically what's happening is these are guys who've come back with Italian fashions. So they're wearing multicolored stockings, very sort of tight britches. Their coats are considered too short. Massive wigs.
1770年的《牛津杂志》。确实有一种动物，非男非女，一种中性的东西，最近在我们中间出现了。它被称为“通心粉”。它说话没有意义。它微笑没有愉悦。它吃东西没有胃口。它骑马没有锻炼。它寻花问柳没有激情。所以有一种女性化的感觉。基本上发生的事情是，这些家伙带着意大利的时尚回来了。所以他们穿着五颜六色的长筒袜，非常紧身的马裤。他们的外套被认为太短了。巨大的假发。
And wigs that, I mean, the claim is that these wigs were half the size of a man. Yeah. I mean, I don't know. And they're actually kind of being carried by servants. Yeah. And then they'd have a little hat on them on the top. And you could only get the hat off with a sword
而且那些假发，我的意思是，有人声称这些假发有半个人那么大。是的。我的意思是，我不知道。而且它们实际上是由仆人扛着的。是的。然后他们会在上面戴一顶小帽子。而且你只能用剑才能把帽子拿下来，
because it was so high up. And also they didn't eat roast beef, which is always a bad sign. Well, yeah. I mean, they weren't eat roast beef, which is always a bad sign. Yeah, I mean, they weren't very, they were seen as un-British. So the Universal magazine, two years after that, 1772, said,
因为它太高了。而且他们也不吃烤牛肉，这总是一个坏兆头。嗯，是的。我的意思是，他们不太……他们被视为“非英国人”。所以两年后的1772年，《环球杂志》说，
you may know a macaroni when you come near him by his essence and his scented waters. And you will discover him by seeing everything about him most extravagantly outre. He attends at auctions where he picks up the names of painters and vomits them forth at all occasions. That's, I mean, that kind of runs through, doesn't it? So Italian dancing masters are objects of absolute hilarity.
当你靠近一个“通心粉”时，你可以通过他的香水和香水味认出他。你会发现他身上的一切都极其夸张。他参加拍卖会，在那里学会了画家的名字，并在所有场合大肆吹嘘。我的意思是，那种感觉一直存在，不是吗？所以意大利舞蹈大师是绝对的笑料。
And you think of Room with a View with Cecil. So I think all of those things are picking up all this macaroni stuff. So I think Dickens and Co. are absolutely picking up this stuff 100 years later. Actually, Dominic, wouldn't you say the influence of all the opera in Italia 90 in creating a kind of slightly effeminate class? Feminizing football. Yeah, I think there's a lot of truth in that. And then the arrival of Italian players and indeed of Italian football
你会想到《看得见风景的房间》里的塞西尔。所以我认为所有这些都在捕捉所有这些“通心粉”的东西。所以我认为狄更斯等人100年后绝对是在捕捉这些东西。其实，多米尼克，难道你不认为1990年意大利世界杯上所有歌剧的影响，创造了一种稍微女性化的阶层吗？让足球女性化。是的，我认为这很有道理。然后意大利球员的到来，以及意大利足球的到来，
on Channel 4 in the 1990s was part of a sort of gentrification of, yeah, a demasculine proletarianisation of football. Because there's a kind of ambivalence there. Because on the one hand, there is a sense of Italy as, you know, mafiosi, diving, unlike our brave British, our brave English strikers. Yeah. We would never do that.
在90年代的第四频道，是足球绅士化的一部分，是的，足球的去男性化无产阶级化。因为那里有一种矛盾心理。因为一方面，人们认为意大利人是黑手党、假摔，不像我们勇敢的英国人，我们勇敢的英格兰前锋。是的。我们永远不会那样做。
So there is that. But then, of course, there is also the sense of of you know this macaroni tradition well the macaroni the other thing about the macaroni thing is there's obviously a whole lot of stuff about sexuality and gender kind of bound up with that about go on so so there's somebody wrote a journal of a macaroni um and it reads like that i can't read at all it is very funny Rise at 11, survey my sweet this is a diary, this is what they do in the day survey my sweet face in the glass and pick my teeth for half an hour, breakfast at 12 saunter to the park and stare
所以确实有那种感觉。但当然，还有那种……你知道，这种“通心粉”传统。嗯，关于“通心粉”的另一件事是，显然有很多关于性和性别的东西与此捆绑在一起。继续说。所以有人写了一本“通心粉”日记，读起来就像……我根本读不下去，这太搞笑了。11点起床，在镜子里审视我甜美的脸，剔牙半小时，12点吃早餐，漫步到公园，盯着
at the women for the reputation of having a taste for them, so he's only doing it for the reputation, not because he wants to stare at the women and then he goes to the coffee house, goes to the theatre 9 o'clock, take a woman of the goes to the coffee house, goes to the theatre. Nine o'clock, take a woman of the town to the Shakespeare, treat her with a bottle of champagne and leave her as I found her. And the sort of damning thing there is that he's leaving her as he found her.
女人看，为了获得对她们有品位的名声，所以他这样做只是为了名声，而不是因为他想盯着女人看。然后他去咖啡馆，9点去剧院，带一个城里的女人去莎士比亚剧院，请她喝一瓶香槟，然后像我发现她时那样离开她。而这里最令人诟病的是，他像发现她时那样离开了她。
He's not sort of debauching her because the assumption, you know, the implication is because he's gay. And all of this stuff is just for show. So that's kind of, there is always this stuff about Italian effeminacy, which runs through, I mean, I think it's probably gone now, but no one would look at Giorgio Chiellini, the captain of Italy, and say he's an effeminate man. He's not. He looks like a kind of Roman centurion from central casting.
他没有那种败坏她，因为假设，你知道，暗示是因为他是同性恋。所有这些都只是为了表演。所以这就是……关于意大利人的女性化总是存在这种东西，我的意思是，我想现在可能已经消失了，但没有人会看着意大利队长乔治·基耶利尼说他是一个女性化的男人。他不是。他看起来像是一个来自选角中心的罗马百夫长。
But that obviously runs through from, I say, the 18th century to the mid-20s, to mods, when mods were sometimes dissed by rockers as effeminate and a bit italianate yeah obviously italian because they wore italian fashions and they had their scooters and they went to coffee bars and things exactly so there's so there's this kind of association with with um youth culture yeah fashion yeah um gender bending absolutely cutting it so cutting edge and so they um the uh yankee Fashion. Yeah. Gender bending. Absolutely. Cutting it. So cutting edge. And so the Yankee Doodle went to town. Wow, yes.
但这显然从18世纪一直延续到20世纪中期，到摩德族（mods），当摩德族有时被摇滚乐手嘲笑为女性化和有点意大利化时。是的，显然是意大利化，因为他们穿着意大利时尚，有他们的踏板车，去咖啡吧等等。没错，所以有一种与青年文化、时尚、性别弯曲的联系，绝对是前沿的。所以他们……洋基歌（Yankee Doodle）进城了。哇，是的。
This is fascinating. So that's a joke about Americans being backward. Being backward and trying to be macaronis and failing. So this is a really weird thing. And our American listeners will find this weird because they think of Yankee Doodle Dandy as a patriotic song, but it began as an insult that British redcoats would sing during the American War of Independence to mock the Americans. So the first, I think, is it the first verse? I don't know. Yankee Doodle went to town riding on a pony,
这太迷人了。所以这是一个关于美国人落后的笑话。落后，试图成为“通心粉”却失败了。所以这是一件非常奇怪的事情。我们的美国听众会觉得这很奇怪，因为他们认为《洋基歌》是一首爱国歌曲，但它最初是英国红衫军在美国独立战争期间唱的一种侮辱，用来嘲笑美国人。所以第一段，我想，是第一段吗？我不知道。《洋基歌》进城了，骑着小马，
stuck a feather in his cap and called it macaroni. It's basically exactly that. They're putting a feather in their cap because they think it's going to make them look like a dandy. Because actually you need a massive wig. Yeah, because they're just hayseeds. Exactly that. You know, they're putting a feather in their cap because they think it's going to make them look like a dandy. Because actually you need a massive wig. Yeah, because they're just sort of hayseeds. Exactly that. So you get that tradition going through with Byron being the famous example
在帽子上插了一根羽毛，称之为“通心粉”。基本上就是这样。他们在帽子上插了一根羽毛，因为他们认为这会让他们看起来像个花花公子。因为实际上你需要一顶巨大的假发。是的，因为他们只是乡巴佬。完全正确。你知道，他们在帽子上插了一根羽毛，因为他们认为这会让他们看起来像个花花公子。因为实际上你需要一顶巨大的假发。是的，因为他们只是某种乡巴佬。完全正确。所以你会有那种传统，拜伦就是一个著名的例子，
of a lord who goes to Italy, who writes about it, you know, his gibbon had done, about its ruins, about its beauty, but also mourning the fact that it's basically prostrate and humiliated, that it's under the thumb of the church, it's under the thumb of the Austrians, it's fragmented, there's no prospect of it recovering its former greatness. But then I guess over the 19th century, gradually it does. Yeah.
一个去意大利的贵族，他写了关于它的文章，你知道，吉本也做过，关于它的废墟，关于它的美，但也哀悼它基本上是俯卧和受辱的事实，它在教会的控制下，在奥地利的控制下，它是支离破碎的，没有恢复其昔日伟大的前景。但我想在19世纪，它逐渐恢复了。是的。
And the key man here... This is where the biscuits come in. The key man here is Garibaldi. Now, I'll come to... Well, maybe we should start with the biscuit. Everybody... To me, a Garibaldi
而这里关键的人物……这就是饼干出现的地方。这里关键的人物是加里波第。现在，我会谈到……嗯，也许我们应该从饼干开始。每个人……对我来说，加里波第饼干
is a very, very fine biscuit. I know people often have these World Cups of biscuits on Twitter and so on. World Cups are a ridiculous idea. Yeah. It's so tawdry and shallow, isn't it? Anyway, they have...
是一种非常非常好的饼干。我知道人们经常在推特上举行这种饼干世界杯之类的活动。世界杯是一个荒谬的想法。是的。这太俗气和肤浅了，不是吗？无论如何，他们有……
They have a word... Garibaldi never does as well in these competitions as i think it should because i think it's a bit boring no i think the garibaldi is a marvelous biscuit anyway listen dominic do you know when the garibaldi was invented tom um 1865 oh god you've clearly swatted up on it it's 1861 was it it's 1861 yeah i'm guessing it was named after garibaldi it's such a shame the listeners can't see just how childishly pleased you are that you always got it right so yes um garibaldi you know most people will have some vague awareness that he's a guy in a red shirt and he
他们有一个词……加里波第在这些比赛中从来没有像我认为的那样表现出色，因为我认为它有点无聊。不，我认为加里波第是一种美妙的饼干。无论如何，听着，多米尼克，你知道加里波第饼干是什么时候发明的吗，汤姆？嗯，1865年。哦，天哪，你显然已经做过功课了。是1861年吗？是1861年，是的。我猜它是以加里波第命名的。听众们看不到你因为答对了而表现出的那种孩子气的满足感，真是太遗憾了。所以是的，嗯，加里波第，你知道大多数人会模糊地意识到他是一个穿着红衬衫的家伙，他
um is key in the unification of italy um so he was quite famous in England before the unification of Italy, because he was famous for his role in, he tried to lead a revolution in 1848. And then he'd gone around kind of trying to raise funds. So he'd gone to America, for example. And actually, when he was going to America in 1854, he stopped in Newcastle. dan jackson is a friend of the podcast who's always tweeting us things that he knows far more about than we do but they always have a newcastle link they always have a newcastle link and he will definitely know more about this than us garibaldi arrives in march 1854 and he gives speeches to all these working men for italian unification for liberty and so on and this is precisely the kind of cause that's very popular
嗯，是意大利统一的关键人物。所以他在意大利统一之前在英国就很有名，因为他以他在1848年试图领导一场革命的角色而闻名。然后他到处试图筹集资金。所以他去过美国，例如。实际上，当他在1854年去美国时，他在纽卡斯尔停留过。丹·杰克逊是这个播客的朋友，他总是向我们推特发送一些他比我们了解得多的事情，但它们总是与纽卡斯尔有关。它们总是与纽卡斯尔有关，他肯定比我们更了解这一点。加里波第于1854年3月抵达，他向所有这些工人发表了关于意大利统一、自由等的演讲，这正是19世纪中期在工人团体和具有自由思想的人们中非常受欢迎的那种事业。你知道，让我们建立意大利，摆脱这些旧帝国的枷锁等等。他被赠予了一把金剑，这是纽卡斯尔人民通过公众捐款购买的，上面刻着：“由泰恩赛德人民，欧洲自由之友，1854年4月赠予加里波第将军。”
with kind of, you know, working men's groups and sort of liberal-minded people in the middle of the 19th century. You know, let's build Italy, throw off the shackles of these old empires and so on. He's given a golden sword bought by public donation by the people of Newcastle, inscribed with the words, presented to General Garibaldi by the people of Tyneside, friends of European freedom, April 1854.
天哪，我可以想象丹在写信给你时那种满足的样子。完全正确。所以六年后的1860年，加里波第在历史上有了他最著名的时刻，当时他领导了所谓的“千人远征”，登陆西西里岛。他要攻击……“千人远征”登陆西西里岛。他要攻击两西西里王国，该王国由波旁王朝统治。那是更多的饼干。
God, I can imagine Dan purring as he wrote to you about that. Exactly. So then six years later, Garibaldi has his most famous sort of moment in history when he leads what's called the expedition of Emile, the Thousand, to land in Sicily. And he's going to attack the expedition of Emile the Thousand to land in Sicily. And he's going to attack the kingdom of the two Sicilies, which is run by the Bourbons. That's more biscuits.
也是一种饼干，但那是后来的事了。也是一种非常好的饼干，我认为，但不如加里波第饼干好。现在，他在英国对此有巨大的支持，因为，同样，他是一位自由主义英雄，某种自由的英雄等等。所以数万英镑被捐赠来帮助他的远征。《泰晤士报》的战地记者全程跟随他，但至关重要的是，皇家海军支持加里波第在西西里的登陆。所以他们派出了“汉尼拔号”战舰，讽刺的是，在所有船只中，派出了“汉尼拔号”和两艘炮艇，“阿耳戈号”和“无畏号”。
Also a biscuit, but later. Also a very good biscuit, I think, but not as good as a Garibaldi. Now, he has huge support in England for this, because, again, he's a liberal hero, sort of hero of liberty and stuff. So tens of thousands of pounds are donated to help his expedition the times war correspondent goes with him all the way or every sort of step of the way but crucially the royal navy supports um garibaldi's landings in sicily so they send hms hannibal hannibal ironically of all the ships there to send hms hannibal and two gunboats, Argus and Intrepid.
他们基本上使他能够登陆。波旁王朝的船只，不如我们的好，无法阻止他。加里波第登陆西西里，他占领了西西里，然后他去了意大利，他向那不勒斯进军，并引发了这一系列坦率地说，对我来说，难以理解和令人困惑的事件。但它最终确实涉及了向罗马进军，对吧？
And they basically make it possible for him to land. The Bourbon ships, which aren't as good as ours, can't sort of do anything to stop him. Garibaldi lands in Sicily, he captures Sicily, then he goes over to Italy and he sort of marches up towards Naples and sets in train this great sort of series of, frankly, to me, incomprehensible and baffling events. But it does ultimately involve a march on Rome, right?
是的，他们最终向罗马进军，完全正确。教皇对此持敌对态度。是的，教皇说教皇军队与皮埃蒙特王国作战，那是加里波第的盟友。那么这在英国的反天主教舆论中是如何表现的呢？我认为这……我的意思是，非常好。我的意思是，反天主教的人，但人们普遍绝对喜欢这个。
Yeah, they march on Rome eventually, exactly. And the Pope is hostile to this. Yeah, the Pope says papal troops fight against the kingdom of Piedmont, which is the Garibaldi's big ally. And so how is this playing with kind of anti-Catholic opinion back in England? I think it's all... I mean, incredibly well. I mean, the anti-Catholic people, but people generally absolutely love this.
所以到了1864年，当加里波第取得了很多成功并回到伦敦时，有……我的意思是，他在伦敦街头受到了我想是50万人的欢迎，考虑到当时的背景，这令人难以置信。因为他是一位自由战士。他是一位自由战士，完全正确。他是反天主教的。
So by 1864, when Garibaldi's had a lot of success and he comes back to London, there is... I mean, he's met by, I think, half a million people in London on the streets, which is unbelievable when you think in the context of the time. Because he's a freedom fighter. He's a freedom fighter, exactly. He's anti-Catholic.
他是所有让英国人兴奋的东西。他住在斯塔福德宫，他太受欢迎了，以至于仆人们通过装瓶他洗脸盆里的肥皂水发了一笔财。天哪，就像披头士乐队一样。并把它们卖掉。完全就是那样。但伟大和优秀的人也见了他，
He's everything that kicks the English boxes. He stays at a place called Stafford House, and he's so popular that the servants make a fortune by bottling the soap suds from his washbasin. God's like the Beatles. And selling them. It's exactly that. But the great and the good ones see him as well,
帕默斯顿勋爵之类的人。当时有巨大的贸易。加里波第是19世纪被纪念得最多的人之一，在小饰品、商品中。所以有玩偶、盘子、大酒杯、陶瓷和明信片，因为有他的照片。他在丁尼生的花园里种了一棵树。
Lord Palmerston and people like that. There was a massive trade. Garibaldi is one of the most memorialised men of the 19th century in knick-knacks, in merchandise. So there's dolls and there's plates and there's tankards and there's ceramics and there's postcards because there's photos of him. He plants a tree in Tennyson's garden.
所以基本上……他是一位名人。所以基本上意大利的建立归功于我们。这是因为海军，因为归功于我们和加里波第。而且有一个足球联系，因为他去诺丁汉或诺丁汉郡发表了演讲，或者有某种诺丁汉郡的联系，这意味着当人们开始组建诺丁汉森林足球俱乐部时，
So basically... He's a celebrity. So basically the establishment of Italy is down to us. It's because of the Navy and because of down to us and Garibaldi. And there's a football link because he goes and gives a speech, I think, in Nottingham or Nottinghamshire, or there's some Nottinghamshire connection, which means that when people start playing as Nottingham Forest Football Club,
他们戴着红色的流苏帽子，被称为“加里波第帽”。后来当他们决定帽子不适合足球时，他们改穿红色的衬衫，以纪念加里波第。所以有一个足球联系。英国各地仍然有大量的道路被称为“加里波第街”或“加里波第路”。至少有八家酒吧，加里波第酒吧，还有饼干。所以加里波第留下了令人难以置信的遗产，
they wear red tasseled hats called Garibaldi hats. And then later on when they decide that hats are not suitable for football, they wear red shirts instead in honour of Garibaldi. So there's a football link. There are still tons of roads all across Britain called Garibaldi Street or Garibaldi Road. There are at least eight pubs, Garibaldi pubs, and the biscuit. So Garibaldi leaves this incredible legacy,
而波旁王朝真的无法竞争。他们也有饼干，但他们的饼干直到19……嗯，饼干很早就推出了，但直到1930年代他们才把名字加在上面，到那时已经太晚了，因为正如我们所知，意大利在1930年代由不同的管理层管理。
and the Bourbons can't really compete. They also have a biscuit, but their biscuit isn't launched until the 19... Well, the biscuit is launched early, but they don't add their name to it until the 1930s, by which time it is far too late, because Italy is under different management, as we all know know in the 1930s
我认为这表明了我本质上反动的性格，我确实更喜欢波旁饼干。是的，好吧，这说明了……作为波旁饼干，你什么都没学到，什么也没忘记，或者无论那是什么，我不记得了，但你作为一个天生的革命者，所以……嗯，是的，你那热血的马克思主义，完全正确，完全正确。你提到了足球，是的，嗯，当然，著名的细节是，AC米兰不是作为板球俱乐部开始的吗？我想是的，确实是。完全正确，这就是为什么它叫米兰而不是米兰诺。是的，所以它是由英国人创立的，非常……你知道，就像奥古斯丁来到坎特伯雷传播基督教一样。是的。
i think it's an index of my essentially reactionary character that i do actually prefer bourbons yeah well that says yeah as a bourbon you have learned nothing and forgotten nothing or yeah whatever it is i can't remember what it is but you as a kind of instinctive revolutionary so um yeah your red blooded marxism exactly exactly you you mentioned football yeah um of course the the famous detail is that uh ac milan does it not begin as a cricket club i think it does it does exactly that's why it's called milan rather than milano yes so it's founded by english very much you know, rather like Augustine coming to Canterbury and spreading Christianity. Yeah.
英国人去米兰，建立了一个板球俱乐部，建立了一个足球俱乐部。令人失望的是，意大利人对板球的热情不如对足球的热情。但我也相信尤文图斯，它是迄今为止最受欢迎的意大利球队，在整个意大利都受到支持，不仅仅是在都灵。尤文图斯的黑白颜色来自诺茨郡。所以诺丁汉，我的意思是，这基本上是一个诺丁汉郡与意大利关系的播客，而不是……所以当意大利在温布利比赛时，他们确实会回家。
English people go to Milan, set up a cricket club, set up a football club. Disappointingly, the Italians aren't as keen on cricket as they are on football. But also, I believe Juventus, which is by far the most popular Italian team, supported all across Italy, not just in Turin. Juventus got their black and white colours from Notts County. So the Nottingham, I mean, this is basically a Nottinghamshire-Italy relations podcast rather than a... So it really is the case that when Italy play at Wembley, they will be coming home.
他们会回家。非常好。但是，汤姆，所以此时，意大利在英国圈子里，无论高低，都被认为非常好。但到了20世纪，我认为可以公平地说，总的来说，人们在政治上对意大利人的评价很低。所以在第一次世界大战中，意大利在抽签的另一边，正如人们所说的那样。所以他们本应与德国和奥地利结盟，基本上在战争开始一年后，他们完全打破了那个联盟，在背后捅了盟友一刀，并决定攻击奥地利，他们以最……
They will be coming home. Very good. But, Tom, so at this point, Italy is thought of very well in British circles, high and low. But then in the 20th century, I think it's fair to say that by and large, people had very low opinion of the Italians politically. So in the First World War, Italy lines up, as it were, on the other side of the draw at the beginning. So they're supposed to be in an alliance with um uh with with germany and with austria and basically about a year into the war they they completely break that alliance stab their allies in the back and decide they're going to attack austria and they they they do that in the most
我的意思是，很难……我不想听起来有偏见，但很难为他们的行为辩护，因为他们以一种非常卑鄙的方式这样做。他们基本上对英国和法国说，你们会给我们什么来加入你们？我们要土地。我们要奥地利的领土。而所有英国政客，他们都想拉拢意大利。
i mean it's very hard to um i don't want to sound like i'm biased but it's very hard to defend their behavior here because they do it in a very weaselly way. They basically say to Britain and France, what will you give us to join you? We want land. We want Austrian territory. And all the British sort of politicians, they want Italy on side.
但阿斯奎斯，例如，他形容意大利是“那个最贪婪、最滑头、最背信弃义的强权”。必须立即拉拢意大利。他说，她贪婪而滑头。丘吉尔形容意大利是“欧洲的妓女”。劳合·乔治说，他们是最令人鄙视的国家。杰基·费舍尔，第一海务大臣，他说，意大利人只是手摇风琴手。他们一点用处都没有。我可以加入一些对意大利的辱骂吗？
But Asquith, for example, he described Italy as that most voracious, slippery and perfidious power. It's important to bring Italy in at once. Greedy and slippery she is, he says. Churchill described Italy as the harlot of Europe. Lloyd George, they are the most contemptible nation. Jackie Fisher, who was the first sea lord, he said, the Italians are mere organ grinders. They will be no use whatsoever. Could I join in with some abuse of Italy?
请便。是的。好吧。所以第一次世界大战，显然，他们站在我们这边。是的。第二次世界大战，他们……当然，非常血腥的战役。第二次世界大战，他们没有。他们反对我们。他们确实没有。而且当然是由墨索里尼领导的。
Do. Yeah. Okay. So First World War, obviously, they were on our side. Yeah. Second World War, they... Of course, incredibly bloody campaign. Second World War, they weren't. They were against us. They weren't, indeed. And led by Mussolini, of course.
也像第一次世界大战一样进入得很晚。是的，是的。这是韦维尔发给我的。是的。好吧，他不是自己发的，对吧？他自己说了这个，但我当时……不，他没有发给你。你说他自己说了这个，但我知道他没有
Also entered late, as they had in the First World War. Yep, yep. I've been sent this by Wavell. Yeah. Well, he didn't send it himself, did he? He said this himself, but I was... No, he didn't send it to you. You said he said this himself but i know he didn't
发给你。你说不，不，这是我的朋友黛西·克里斯托德利发来的，她会来谈论考试，考试的历史，以配合……听起来更像是一个威胁，A-level或GCSE成绩……所以韦维尔，是的，这是一个朋友，这太棒了。我们可以列出那些点燃战火的国家：德国和日本，愚蠢、没教养的孩子，他们从未受到过适当的教育或学会良好的国际礼仪。他们愚蠢的小女朋友，意大利，怀着一些廉价乐趣的希望加入了他们，现在发现自己被两个真正的坏男孩带坏了。这对她来说既不便宜，也不有趣。我的意思是，这就是我认为我们希望评论员在周日晚上提供的评论。
send it to you you said no no this was sent by this was sent by my friend um daisy christodley who will be coming on and talking about exams history of exams uh to coincide with that sound more like a threat a level of gcse results um so wavel yeah this is a mate this is fabulous we can name the nations who started the fire germ Germany and Japan, stupid, ill-bred children who have never been properly brought up or learnt good international manners. Their silly little girlfriend, Italy, joined them in hopes of some cheap fun and now finds herself being taken for a ride with two really bad boys. And that is not going to be cheap for her or much fun. I mean, that's the kind of commentary that I think we want from the commentators
但那太普遍了。我的意思是，我想因为“通心粉”之后那种东西的重量，英国人在二战中几乎不可能以任何其他方式看待意大利人。所以有一位英国军官的描述，
on Sunday night. But that was so common. I mean, I suppose because of the weight of the sort of post-macaroni stuff, it was almost impossible for the British in World War II to think of the Italians in any other way. So there's a description of one British officer
他描述意大利人从利比亚前往埃及，他说他们看起来好像是在去参加生日派对的路上，还有所有关于意大利坦克只有倒档的笑话。好吧，这就是重点。所以当我们1941年在托布鲁克等地获胜时，嗯，有一些来自澳大利亚记者艾伦·穆尔黑德的精彩描述，他写了一本关于沙漠战争的精彩书籍，他说基本上当我到达意大利营地时，我发现里面到处都是亚麻床单、蕾丝边的制服、流苏腰带、孔雀帽。然后后来，有一个大箱子之类的东西，他们往里面看，他们说，
who describes the Italians heading from Libya into Egypt he says they looked as if they're on their way to a birthday party and also all the jokes about Italian tanks only having a reverse well this is the thing so when we capture Tobruk and so on in 1941 um there's some wonderful descriptions from the Australian journalist Alan Moorhead who wrote a brilliant book about the war in the desert and he says basically when I got to the Italian camp I found it full of linen bed sheetsets, lace-trimmed uniforms, tasseled belts, peacock hats. And then later on, there's a big box or something and they look in it and they say,
罐装樱桃、火腿罐头、凤尾鱼和面包。基本上，意大利人是打包去野餐的。好吧，你还记得我们做的关于游戏、关于战争游戏的剧集吗？有一个关于意大利战争的大型战争游戏。没错。每一轮你都必须有足够的燃料来烧水煮意大利军队的意大利面。
jars of bottled cherries, tins of ham, anchovies and bread. Basically, the Italians are packed for a picnic. Well, you remember the episode we did on games, on war games. And there's a massive war game about the war in Italy. That's right. Where every round you have to have enough fuel to boil up the water for the Italian army's pasta.
所以那种对意大利军事努力的嘲笑一直延续到今天。但公平地说，多米尼克，不是吗？是的。第二次世界大战中对意大利的入侵是极其残酷、极其血腥的。是的。而且实际上，英国人对游击队产生了巨大的钦佩和尊重。我想他们确实有，是的。
So that kind of mockery of Italian war martial efforts carries on right into the present day. But it is fair to say, is it not, Dominic? Yes. That the invasion of Italy in the Second World War is incredibly brutal, incredibly bloody. Yes. And actually, the British come to have a huge admiration and respect for the partisans. I think they do, yes.
而且说实话，他们有点害怕他们。但我还认为这非常迷人，汤姆，战后，人们对德国人和日本人仍然有很多积怨。而且有那种人们不买德国或日本车的经典做法。但从来没有人那样说韦士柏踏板车、菲亚特或意大利咖啡。因为我认为意大利人被认为为他们自己的解放做出了贡献。我想部分原因是这样。但我还认为部分原因是韦维尔之前说的那个引语，即意大利人被误导了，
And they're slightly frightened of them, to be honest. But I also think it's really fascinating, Tom, how after the war, there is still a lot of bad blood towards the Germans and the Japanese. And there's the classic thing of people who won't buy a German or Japanese car. But nobody ever says that about Vespa scooters or about Fiat or about Italian coffee. Because I think the Italians are felt to have contributed to their own liberation. I think it's partly that. But I also think it's partly that Wavell quote that you said earlier on, that the Italians have been led astray,
他们……有一种稍微居高临下的态度。我的意思是，我会说一件事。所以如果有人在听，心想，哦，这非常沙文主义，他们在嘲笑意大利人。战争中意大利人的故事还有另一个方面，实际上非常令人清醒，那就是在英国的意大利人发生了什么。
that they, there's this sort of slightly patronising attitude. I mean, I will say one thing. So in case people are listening to it and thinking, oh, this is very sort of jingoistic and they're laughing at Italians. There is another element to the Italian story in the war, which is actually very sobering, which is what happens to the Italians in Britain.
所以有很多意大利人，特别是在苏格兰，他们受到了相当残忍的对待。所以人们去砸碎他们商店的窗户。我的意思是，他们中有些人是在第一次世界大战中为我们在军队中战斗过的意大利人。而他们的商店都被砸了。他们被抢劫了。
So there's a lot of Italians, particularly in Scotland, and they are pretty atrociously treated. So people go and smash the windows of their shops. I mean, some of them are Italians who'd fought for us in the First World War in our army. And their shops are all smashed. They're looted.
我想在爱丁堡，一位店主被枪杀。人群暴动，他们殴打人们等等。诸如此类的事情，我的意思是，就像另一块饼干。麦维他（McVitie）是饼干工厂。他们直接解雇了所有意大利员工。而丘吉尔
One shop owner in, I think, Edinburgh is shot dead. And the crowds kind of riot and they beat people up and stuff. Things like, I mean, just little things like another biscuit. McVitie is the biscuit factory. They sacked all their Italian staff out of hand. And Churchill
基本上，有人问他，我们应该怎么处理意大利人？他名言道：“把他们全抓起来。”所以英国的每个意大利人都被围捕了。成百上千的人被关进营地，嗯，成千上万的人被送上一艘名为“阿兰多拉之星”号的船。船上有1200人，主要是意大利人，也有德国人，其中一些是难民。他们被送往加拿大的营地，但途中被德国U型潜艇鱼雷击中。大约800人丧生。所以这些是意大利服务员，人们，我的意思是，字面上的手摇风琴手，或者在冰淇淋店工作的人等等，
was basically, he's asked, what should we do about the Italians? And he famously says, collar the lot. So every Italian in Britain is rounded up. Hundreds of them are put into camps well thousands of them um hundreds are put on a ship called the arandora star one there were 1200 people mostly italians but germans as well some of them refugees they're sent off to um camps in canada but they're torpedoed by a german u-boat along the way. And about 800 people are killed. So these are Italian waiters, people who, I mean, literally organ grinders, or people who work in ice cream shops and so on,
所有意大利人在战前做的经典事情。他们中有800人死亡。其余的人只是被送上另一艘船，然后被送到澳大利亚。当他们到达澳大利亚时，他们被殴打，所有的财产都被偷走了。所以这是一个非常悲伤和可耻的篇章。所以这并不全是乐趣和游戏。我的意思是，这个故事也有悲伤和黑暗的篇章。
all the classic things that Italians did before the war. 800 of them die. The rest just put on another ship and then sent to Australia. When they get to Australia, they're kind of beaten up and all their possessions are stolen from them. So it's a really sad and sort of shameful chapter. So it's not all kind of fun and games, this. I mean, there are sort of sad and dark chapters to the story as well.
然后战后，我的意思是，关系一直很好，我想。我的意思是，意大利人超越了我们，不是吗？超越了。是的。好吧，他们有这种巨大的经济增长。我的意思是，1950年代和60年代的这种经济奇迹。所以我们花了三个世纪嘲笑他们经济落后，
And then post-war, I mean, relations have been pretty good, I think. I mean, the Italians surpass us, don't they? Il surpassu. Yes. Well, they have this tremendous economic growth. I mean, the Italians surpass us, don't they? Il surpassu. Yes. Well, they have this tremendous economic growth. I mean, this economic miracle in the 1950s and 60s. So we've spent three centuries sneering at them for being economically backward,
然后他们超越了我们。但真正引人注目的是遗产。所以你在最开始谈到了罗马，罗马是中心，罗马更复杂、更文明。所以在那些我写过的时期，比如1950年代和1960年代，人们绝对有那种意大利文化的观点。
and then they zoom ahead of us. But what's really remarkable, actually, is the legacy. So you talked right at the beginning about Rome and Rome being the centre and Rome being more sophisticated and more civilised. So in the periods that I've written about, let's say the 1950s and 1960s, people absolutely had that view of Italian culture.
意大利电影，费里尼和安东尼奥尼等等，它们更具知识性。意大利时尚是主流，你知道，意大利鞋，意大利裤子。正如我们所说，摩德族，你知道，竭尽全力看起来像意大利人。多米尼克，我的意思是，还有那些让乔叟和也许莎士比亚着迷的东西的持久吸引力，时间诗歌，是的，托斯卡纳是一种速记，不是吗？对于哦，是的，上中产阶级精英品味。是的，我的意思是，
Italian films, Fellini and Antonioni and so on, they were more highbrow. Italian fashion was the thing, you know, Italian shoes, Italian trousers. As we said, mods, you know, went out of their way to look like Italians. Dominic, I mean also the the enduring appeal of the stuff that enthused you know chaucer and perhaps shakespeare the time poetry and yeah tuscany is a kind of shorthand isn't it for oh yes upper middle class elite tastes yeah i mean
如果你是《卫报》的专栏作家，法律规定你必须去托斯卡纳度假。这就是笑话，不是吗？我的意思是，那绝对仍然是速记。所以就像在14世纪一样，在21世纪，托斯卡纳，它唤起了一切。其中有多少与罗马的遗产有关，汤姆？我不认为它与罗马的遗产有太大关系。你不觉得吗？不，我认为它与风景的美、艺术的美有关。我认为这更多是文艺复兴的事情。
if you're a guardian colonist by law you have to go on holiday to Tuscany. That's the joke, isn't it? I mean, that is absolutely still the shorthand. So just as in the 14th century, in the 21st century, Tuscany, it conjures up everything. How much of that is to do with the legacy of Rome, Tom? I don't think it has much to do with the legacy of Rome. Don't you? No, I think it's to do with the beauty of the landscape, with the beauty of the art. I think it's much more a Renaissance thing.
我不这么认为。我认为如果你对一个孩子说，例如，罗马，很多人喜欢去罗马。是的，但它是……不，但托斯卡纳，作为汉普斯特德人的速记。好吧，托斯卡纳特别，好吧。托斯卡纳特别是一种……它是佛罗伦萨和……
I don't. I think if you say to a child, for example, Rome, lots of people love going to Rome. Yeah, but it's... No, but Tuscany, as in short-handedly people from Hampstead. Well, Tuscany specifically, okay. Tuscany specifically is sort of... It's Florence and...
《卫报》读者的幻想。我同意那是文艺复兴的事情。但人们去庞贝，不是吗？作为汉普斯特德人，好吧，它是佛罗伦萨和《卫报》读者的幻想。我同意那是文艺复兴的事情。但人们去庞贝，不是吗？而且他们……我的意思是，我第一次去那不勒斯或罗马时，有一种真正的电光火石般的兴奋感，你知道，这些是真实的，这些是真正的地方。当然，绝对是，我的意思是，是的，当然，如果你是游客，罗马是吸引力的一大部分。但我认为生活方式的事情。是的，它更多是文艺复兴。我认为意大利，你知道，“甜蜜生活”（Dolce Vita）。
The Guardian readers' fantasy. I agree that's kind of a Renaissance thing. But people go to Pompeii, don't they? in short people from hampstead okay it's it's florence and the the guardian reader's fantasy i agree that's kind of a renaissance thing but people go to pompeii don't they and they i mean i the first time i went to naples or indeed to rome there was this real sense of electric excitement you know these are real these are the real places of course absolutely i mean yes of course the rome is a huge part of the appeal if you're a tourist. But I think the lifestyle thing. Yeah, it's more Renaissance. I think the Italian, you know, the Dolce Vita.
我知道它发生在罗马，所以这摧毁了我的论点。但我认为意大利时尚、意大利风格的感觉是植根于文艺复兴的。为了宣传你自己的书《卢比孔河》，它有关于罗马别墅和那不勒斯湾的奢华的最美妙的描述，但他们去了那不勒斯。我的意思是，那不勒斯是一个美妙的城市，它是我在意大利最喜欢的城市。是的，但它不是你会去寻找燃烧的瓦砾堆的地方，高端，这就是我去的目的。人们把垃圾点火，因为黑手党拒绝收集它。是的，是的，但这就是我去的目的。人们把垃圾点火，因为黑手党拒绝收集它。
I know it's set in Rome, so that torpedoes my argument. But I think that the sense of Italian fashion, of Italian style, is kind of rooted in the Renaissance. To plug your own book, Rubicon, which has the most fantastic descriptions of Roman villas and the luxury and the bay of Naples but they've gone Naples I mean Naples is a wonderful city it's my favorite city in Italy yeah but it's it's not a place you'd go for burning piles of rubble high end that's what I go for people people setting rubbish on fire because the mafia refused to collect it yeah yeah but that's what that's what I go for. People setting rubbish on fire because the Mafia refused to collect it.
是的，但这就是让那不勒斯成为一个令人兴奋的旅游地的原因。确实。它在共和国晚期不是那样的。当我第一次去那不勒斯时，B&B里的咖啡机以一种非常令人不安的方式爆炸了。好吧，那不勒斯当然也有
Yeah, but that's what makes Naples such a thrilling place to visit. It does. It's not what it was in the days of the late Republic. When I went to Naples, the coffee machine and B&B exploded in a very disturbing way. Well, Naples also, of course, has
马拉多纳的神龛。确实。我见过那个马拉多纳的神龛。而且，当然，披头士乐队的家。有圣发。他有圣发吗？我想有一根来自马拉多纳头上的头发，充满了可卡因。当，在足球相关方面，当阿根廷
Shrine to Maradona. It does. I've seen that Shrine to Maradona. And, of course, the home of the Beatles. With the holy hair. Does he have holy hair? There's a single hair, I think, from Maradona's head, full of cocaine. When, on a football related, when Argentina
马拉多纳的神龛。确实有。我见过那个马拉多纳的神龛。当然，还有披头士乐队的故乡。还有圣发。他有圣发吗？我想那是马拉多纳头上的一根头发，上面沾满了可卡因。当，在足球相关的事情上，当阿根廷
played Italy in Naples in the 1990 World Cup, Maradona tried to incite the people of Naples against the Italian national team, because he said, you're Neapolitans, you're not Italians. And that actually, we haven't really talked about that at all, about whether Italy is artificial. There was a great book a few years ago by David Gilmour, and he basically said Italy is a fake country.
在1990年世界杯那不勒斯对阵意大利的比赛中，马拉多纳试图煽动那不勒斯人民反对意大利国家队，因为他说，你们是那不勒斯人，你们不是意大利人。事实上，我们还没有真正讨论过这个问题，关于意大利是否是一个人为构建的国家。几年前大卫·吉尔摩写过一本很棒的书，他基本上认为意大利是一个虚假的国家。
It shouldn't really exist as one country. I mean, the trouble is you could say that about so many countries. But I'm sure Italians would say the same about Britain. Well, exactly, they would. Exactly, they would. Which is why they're playing England, not Britain. Yes. So we're just rambling now and I think it's time for
它本不应该作为一个国家存在。我的意思是，问题在于你可以对许多国家这么说。但我相信意大利人对英国也会有同样的看法。嗯，确实，他们会这么说。没错，他们会。这就是为什么他们踢的是英格兰队，而不是英国队。是的。所以我们现在只是在闲聊，我想是时候进行
prediction. I think that Italy will win based on my viewing of the two semifinals. I think 2-1. 2-1. Yes, I think Italy will win. I think they will win. I think they'll win 1-0. I think Italy will win. I think they will win.
预测了。根据我对两场半决赛的观察，我认为意大利会赢。我觉得2-1。2-1。是的，我认为意大利会赢。我认为他们会赢。我觉得他们会1-0获胜。我认为意大利会赢。我认为他们会赢。
I think they'll win 1-0. I think England will huff and puff. And the Italians are too wily in defence. What I will also say about the Italian team is this sweep of history we've been doing from Roman times up to the present day is that they all look like figures from Italian history. Do you know, I was thinking, if he doesn't say that, I will say it.
我觉得他们会1-0获胜。我认为英格兰队会费力进攻。而意大利人在防守上太狡猾了。关于意大利队，我还要说的是，我们一直在回顾从罗马时代到现代的历史，他们看起来都像是意大利历史中的人物。你知道吗，我当时就在想，如果他不这么说，我也会这么说。
So we have said that about the England team, but I think that's even truer. It's unbelievably gratifying, I find, because I'm a man who loves and trades in national stereotypes. So I find it incredibly gratifying when a national team look as they should, when they just look like a casting agency
所以我们对英格兰队也说过同样的话，但我认为这对意大利队来说更贴切。我觉得这令人难以置信地满足，因为我是一个热爱并热衷于国家刻板印象的人。所以当一支国家队看起来就该是那个样子，当他们看起来就像是选角机构
has supplied some Italians. And that's exactly, every man of them, they just look... They couldn't be anybody else. They couldn't be France. They couldn't be Germany. I find all my Jacobean Protestantism kicking in. Yeah. And I kind of imagine them going off to poison nunneries and things.
提供的一群意大利人时，我感到无比满足。确实如此，他们每个人看起来……他们不可能是其他人。他们不可能是法国人。他们不可能是德国人。我感到我内心所有的詹姆斯党新教徒倾向都被激发了。是的。我甚至想象他们去毒害修道院之类的地方。
They have that look. They even did a thing. So I don't know if you saw, but before their penalty shootout with Spain, Italian captain Chiellini. I did. He was kind of doing this fake punching and embracing of the spanish captain and the spanish captain geordie alba just looked so much smaller yeah he was small and he just looked utterly distraught and kind of intimidated i mean that's the wrong word but he was just put
他们确实有那种神态。他们甚至做了一件事。我不知道你有没有看到，在与西班牙的点球大战之前，意大利队长基耶利尼。我看到了。他当时在假装挥拳并拥抱西班牙队长，而西班牙队长乔迪·阿尔巴看起来小得多，是的，他很矮小，看起来完全心烦意乱，有点被吓到了，我的意思是这个词可能不太准确，但他只是被
out that this sort of italian leaning over him putting his arms around him, all of this stuff. I mean, they're crafty, aren't they? They've had thousands of years. And I suspect that they will notch up another victory. Yeah, well. But we will see. Anyway, I've very much enjoyed the Euros this time around, particularly for the opportunity it's provided to Dominic
意大利人那种俯身搂住他的姿态弄得不知所措，所有这些举动。我的意思是，他们很狡猾，不是吗？他们已经有几千年的历史了。我怀疑他们会再添一场胜利。是的，好吧。但我们会拭目以待。无论如何，我非常享受这次欧洲杯，特别是它为多米尼克提供的机会
to talk to you about England's relations uh the various countries that we have played uh so i'm very sad to see it end but i'm also absolutely thrilled that england have made it this far not just for patriotic reasons but because um we've been given the chance to talk about italy as well as denmark ukraine and germany so um thank you to the England team thank you to listening to us and hopefully we will be back maybe for the World Cup, who knows Alright, splendid
让你谈谈英格兰与我们交手过的各个国家的关系，所以我很难过看到它结束，但我也非常激动英格兰能走到这一步，不仅仅是因为爱国原因，还因为我们有机会谈论意大利，以及丹麦、乌克兰和德国，所以感谢英格兰队，感谢你们收听我们的节目，希望我们能回来，也许是为了世界杯，谁知道呢，好的，太棒了
see you all next time, good luck England it's coming home, goodbye Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
下次见，祝英格兰好运，足球回家了，再见。感谢收听《历史的余味》。如需收听额外剧集、抢先收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在restishistorypod.com注册。网址是restishistorypod.com。本集暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。